[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We are here
today with Dan Carlin.
He is the host of two very
popular podcasts, "Hardcore
History" and "Common Sense."
Believe it or not, he's been
in this business since 2005.
DAN CARLIN: 2005.
SPEAKER: And he's had a
tremendous amount of success
in the podcast world.
Influence in the
historical world, as well.
So join me again to welcome Dan.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN CARLIN: You have a
wonderful facility here.
SPEAKER: So most of
you guys are probably
all familiar with the "Hardcore
History" podcast series.
It focuses on deep dives
into historical events,
and puts them in context so that
we can understand them better.
So I wanted to throw Dan a
little bit of a curveball,
and ask him--
he always talks about what
happens if you were there.
What would the
experience be like
if you were on the ground
experiencing that history.
So I wanted to
ask Dan to tell us
about a historical experience
that he experienced,
on the ground, in Dan
Carlin's voice, live today.
DAN CARLIN: Well,
when I got into news--
I got out of college,
I didn't know
what I wanted to
do specifically,
so I got in the news
business somehow.
And I remember--
I was a history major.
And when I was a history major
at University of Colorado,
they actually had, in
the history department,
these pamphlets that said
what to tell your parents
about choosing a history major.
Because everybody said, what
are you going to do with this?
So I got to news, and then
found out that so many
of the reporters--
I was a news guy in LA.
And in LA there's two
kinds of reporters.
There's the kind
that you send out
on real deep difficult stories,
and then there are the ones,
you know, you send out to
do the Hollywood stories,
and all that.
And they're really two
different kinds of reporters.
And the kind of
reporters that I wanted
to be like, I found out
an amazing amount of them
had history as their background.
I remember seeing Connie Chung.
I think she spoke at college.
And I went to the get together,
and it was a journalism
department get together.
And somebody raised their
hand and said, what courses
would you suggest we take that
will help us when we get out
into the news business?
And she said--
I'm paraphrasing
here-- but she said
this is going to be a
really unpopular answer
to tell a bunch of
J students, but I
would take all the courses
you're not getting right now.
I would go to the
geography department.
history department.
She goes, because anything
you're learning in journalism,
they're going to reteach
you, your first six
months on the job.
She says, the stuff
you're not going to get
is the background stuff.
So when I got in the news, all
of a sudden I felt like, OK,
maybe this is a place for
people who've studied history.
And I didn't really realize why
until I'd done it for a while.
And it's because you
have the context.
Right?
And what was fun for
a history major is,
you had this opportunity
to be at events--
to answer your question--
where history was taking place.
So you'd do these
horrible stories that
made you feel bad at the end
of the day, that had nothing
to do-- you know, coffee
roasters downtown opened
a new building, or whatever.
But then sometimes
you'd have an LA riot.
And the LA riots were
the biggest thing
that I ever
personally witnessed.
And I remember being in college.
And I was in
college in Colorado,
and you'd hear these stories
about earthquakes and fires
in Los Angeles.
And I'd call home, and I'd say,
I hear things are just awful.
And my mom would
go, they're nothing.
They're just hyping
that story up.
I would say the LA riots
were the only story that
was really as big on the ground
as everybody thought it was.
I mean, that wasn't
being hyped up at all.
And the story was
so weird, because--
and this was the
lesson, I guess,
when you're talking
about what it's
like to go through history.
Because you have no idea
what's really going on while
you're in it.
And you're trying
to make sense of it.
So on the first
day of the riots--
you had to go in to work.
Now you guys will
all understand this,
you have to go in to work
sometimes when there's
big news stories breaking.
So there's this unconscious
bias to downplay
the importance of the news
story if it's your day off.
Right?
Because you kind of think
there, oh, this isn't so bad.
I remember looking
out over the horizon,
and there's multiple
fires burning.
And I'm thinking, I
don't have to go in.
This isn't a big deal.
I don't have to go in to work.
So two days later they
call me, and scream at me,
and say everybody's at work.
Where are you?
So I get in the car,
head down to work,
and it's like a
nuclear bomb went off.
And it's traffic--
I mean, I lived 15
minutes from work.
It took me an hour and
a half to get there.
And I remember thinking, OK, if
there were ever a nuclear war,
nobody's getting
out of anything.
So I went to the building,
and in the first day
were interviewing looters.
And again, this is
an example of how
a story of a giant
historical importance,
at least for that city, didn't
seem like it at the time.
Right?
You walk up to people carrying
stuff out of buildings,
and you stick a
mic in their face,
and you start interviewing them.
Two days later they were
shooting at the reporters,
and we were interviewing
anybody anymore.
So we started covering
things from the air,
with just helicopters.
So I still remember Laura
Diaz-- who was an anchor at KABC
then-- coming up the
stairs, white as a sheet,
saying they just
shot the helicopter.
We're not going
out there anymore.
And that's when we knew
we couldn't go home.
They brought in cots,
they brought in food.
And then they put a
curfew in my home city.
And I've never seen a
curfew in Los Angeles.
They also shut all the
lights out in Hollywood.
And I'd never seen
the lights out.
But they shut the lights
out because it was back
lighting the soldiers that
they'd brought into the city,
and making them targets.
And so we had a pass
to be out after curfew.
And I'm driving in my
home city, and it's dark,
and there's soldiers
on every street corner.
And I have a scanner
in my car, and you
can hear these-- this
guy's being shot here.
We have somebody charging the--
and it was surreal.
And so I remember thinking
that this is maybe
what it must be like when
you're living through history.
Because you don't
know what's going on.
And you're piecing it
together with other people
who are living through
it at the same time.
And I remember, a couple of
days later, feeling like,
was that all real?
Did that really happen?
And I remember going to
pick up my dry cleaning.
I had, like, three
things in my wardrobe
that could be dry cleaned--
all my nicest clothes.
It was right by the TV station.
And I walk into this
place-- remember, thinking,
did this even really happen--
and I walk into
this dry cleaners,
and there wasn't a stitch
of clothing in the place.
And the windows
were all boarded up.
And like an idiot, I still
presented my ticket to the guy.
[LAUGHTER]
And like an idiot,
he looked at it
like he was considering
the fact that maybe there
were some clothes in the
back on the floor that
hadn't been taken.
And then he handed it back to
me, and he said, no clothes.
And that's when I remember
thinking, OK, I get it.
And then I walked
out of the building,
and I looked at the street.
And the riot had literally taken
out one side of the street,
and stopped right there.
And the other side of
the street was pristine.
And I remember thinking,
OK, this really happened.
It took me a couple of
years to really absorb--
and I had actually watched the
TV specials, and everything
on this event--
before you could really
see it the way it was.
You know they say you
shouldn't write history
for a certain period
of time afterwards?
I still don't think I
fully understand that,
and I was in it.
So that was the biggest
historical event
I ever saw up close.
And it's funny how--
it'll be interesting, I
guess, is what I'm saying,
to read about this
in 50 years and see
how the story's 50 year-- well,
as if I'm going to be here.
But you know, how it will
differ from the experience
I saw on the ground.
And I think that's probably
a pretty good analogy
of what it must be like.
It's a little confusing,
and a little hard
to put in perspective.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
That makes a lot of sense.
And a lot of your
episodes, they really
covered a vast swath of time.
Everything from the Mongols
to the recent world wars.
How do you hear back from
readers who have actually
been in those events?
And how do they
respond to hearing
about their experiences retold?
DAN CARLIN: In that
sense, it's kind of easier
to do earlier stuff.
Because if I get
it wrong, I don't
have to hear from
anybody who was there.
We were talking, before
we did this, about--
I did a show called--
three shows, I
guess it was, called
"Ghosts of the Ostfront," once.
And it was about the Eastern
Front in the Second World War.
And I was looking at it
from the perspective of,
if you're an American,
or someone from Britain,
or France, or any of the Allies
that weren't the Soviet Union,
you have a specific
view of the war.
And to us it's hard to
see, either the Russians--
or certainly the Germans--
as the good guys,
or the aggrieved, or victims
in any way, shape, or form.
So I was trying to
do this show where
I tried to look at it from
the perspective of people
who are, like, caught
in the gears of history.
Right?
I mean, the average person in
that war had no say at all.
Especially in these
dictatorships, right?
There were few conscientious
objectors in Germany.
I said there were
none, and heard
from a bunch of
Jehovah's Witnesses
who said they were beheading
Jehovah's Witnesses in Germany
who wouldn't go into the war.
But I did the show.
We tried to do it
from the perspective
of a bunch of people trapped
in a horrible situation.
And a guy wrote me--
I heard from a lot of Germans.
One guy wrote me, he
said, my grandfather
was on the Eastern Front.
He's never spoken about it.
So he said, I got in the
car and I took a chance.
We were going to
have a long drive.
I put your show in.
We drove for six hours.
My grandfather said nothing.
He said, we parked
at the location,
I turned off the
audio, and he starts
babbling about everything that
happened to him that he's never
told the family.
And I guess-- I'm
trying to remember,
this is years ago now-- but
the guy's point was something
to the effect of,
these are people
who never felt that they
could recount the horror,
and the things that happened
to them, because who wants
to hear it from the bad guys?
Right?
They're human
beings who suffered,
but they were the bad guys.
And anytime anyone brings that
up, all you can think about
is, yeah, but what about the
people on the other side?
Remembering, I think
as we must, that
truthfully, by an accident
of where you were born
and when you were born,
it could have been you.
Could have been me.
And so this idea
that somehow somebody
who was there listened to this
and got something positive out
of it, was so different
from saying the 15-year-old,
today, living, downloaded it got
something positive out of it.
The problem, of
course, is you feel
kind of like you've got
this responsibility now.
And it makes it a heck of a lot
harder to walk in the studio
next time and just blithely
talk about the Eastern
Front in the Second
World War, when
you realize people
that are still
trying to deal
with the scars that
were inflicted on them then,
are listening to it, also.
So there's something
a lot easier
about doing a show on the
Mongols from the 14th century,
than doing a show like--
we were considering doing one on
The New Left in the late 1960s.
The Weather Underground,
the bombings, and all that.
And I said, do I really want
to hear from all those people?
Because they're literally
going to write you and say,
I was there.
You're an idiot.
You don't know what
you're talking about.
And Mongols are easier.
But there's something,
if you do it right--
and that's a bit
of a crapshoot--
but if you do it right,
there's something really
satisfying about
somebody saying, yeah,
we got something really
positive out of that.
SPEAKER: Right.
DAN CARLIN: So that, to
me, is an example, maybe,
about what the new media
can do, a little bit.
Because that's a
really niche market,
speaking to Eastern Front
veterans that are still alive.
But the fact that they got
something out of it was neat.
SPEAKER: And so what happens if
you kind of follow this trend?
You're finding a lot
of positive experiences
from people who
do learn about it.
People who learn
about it differently,
despite actually being there.
What happens if we
go the other way?
What if we don't know
all this history?
DAN CARLIN: You, know I've been
thinking about that a lot, too.
Because I have kids, and
my youngest daughter,
for example, is
not a big reader.
Doesn't like all
this kind of stuff.
And you think to yourself,
OK, if this is representative
of her generation-- and
I don't know that it is--
what would happen if the
great mass of society
really didn't know
anything about the past?
If this became a specialist
endeavor, like biologist,
or something where if
you want to know what
happened 10 years ago, you go
to a specialist, as opposed
to having some sort of context.
And I feel like it's a little
bit like a great experiment.
Because on one hand,
I keep telling myself,
OK, most people didn't
know real history
throughout most of
human experience.
So maybe there's nothing
different about it.
And yet-- we were talking
about this great concept
about, in the
world of the blind,
the one-eyed man is king.
If you're the person--
the one out of a hundred of
your generation likes history--
and you study it, and you
learn context from it,
does that give you a
leg up in your life?
It's hard for me
to know, because I
have this weird
theory that's totally
unsupported by any
evidence that I know of,
that different people have
different ways of organizing
their mental framework.
So I have a friend who's
a mathematical genius.
To him, everything is numbers.
Right?
He organizes his whole frame
of thought through numbers.
I organize mine in
a historical sense.
And a lot of the
people I went to school
with that were history
majors did the same thing.
So I think there's got to be a
whole bunch of different ways
to organize your mind.
But the problem is, is
it makes it really hard
to imagine how other
people, who don't
organize their mind the way you
do, organize their thinking.
So for me, it's all linear.
A equals B, then B
happens, then C happens.
And that's how I think.
So I think with the podcast
we keep thinking about,
how do we make a
podcast for the audience
that the audience likes, when we
don't know about the audience?
And so we decided that the
only thing we can control
is what we like.
And that if we talk about
what I like to talk about,
and that interests
me, eventually you
will self-select your audience,
and they will be people
who like what you like too.
So you will be able
to say, OK, I'll
talk about this,
because I like it,
and I know these people
will like it also.
And so I think that
the people that like it
tend to be people that
organize their thinking
in a historical
linear framework.
I think if you're a numbers
guy you might listen to my show
and find 900 things
wrong with it.
If you're a history guy,
you listen to-- it or gal--
and you go, oh yeah, that
speaks to me somehow.
And so, I mean, I think part of
the new media is the ability,
instead of
broadcasting and having
to appeal to everybody
out there, you can say,
no, no, no, I'm targeting
this little teeny
narrow demographic.
And I like to say, you're
a "Harry Potter" fan, what
are the networks giving you?
Right?
OK, but there's like three
or four podcasts just
on "Harry Potter."
So if that's really
what you like--
or 1950s science fiction comic
books, or classic motorcycles,
or whatever it is--
it might be a small audience
that's interested in that,
but they're passionate about it.
Right?
It's one thing to say, I watch
this TV show that everybody
likes, and I like it too.
It's another thing to have
somebody speaking right
to your soul, in a way
that you can relate to,
about something you love.
And I think, for
me, when I think
about what we're getting
to, history-wise,
I'm not teaching
anybody anything.
We're reveling in
this information.
And some of it's false.
And we have to acknowledge
that some of it's false.
But that doesn't change--
I read these histories
from a hundred years ago,
and they're full of falsities,
and romancing, and racism,
and all these things that
100 years ago, history--
but it's colorful.
And if you can say
to yourself, OK,
I'm going to put aside
the question of facts
for a minute-- because I'm not
so sure our facts today are all
that factual, sometimes--
you can really sort of
swim in that kind of thing.
And if you love history,
it's immensely satisfying.
And so we try to
draw some of that--
because I'm not a historian.
And I think historians
today, and I've
said this before, are
better than any historians
we've ever had.
It's all peer reviewed.
They savage each other.
It's like a science,
which is great
if you're looking for
factual information.
But you lose something.
You lose that--
you know, history
used to be a part
of the humanities.
It still is at a
lot of colleges.
But if you looked
at the list, it
would say, humanities, history.
Well, that puts you
in the same category
with law, language,
religion, poetry,
and all those kind of things.
It's a very different
subject than if it puts you
in the social sciences, which
puts you in with anthropology,
archeology.
And, again, more
scientific, more facts.
But do you lose something
in the transition?
And what I've always wondered
is if maybe you don't even
have two disciplines there.
History as a
humanity, and history
as a social science, because
they almost do different work.
The history as a social science
is rigorously fact-based,
and it's wonderful.
But if I open up a history
book from 50 years ago,
it fails every
test you would have
to pass to be in that category.
But it's immensely
more satisfying
to a non-specialist reader.
And you ask yourself why.
Because there's something
more human about it.
But whenever you're
dealing with people,
we are so variable and weird.
I mean, how do I put you
versus you in these--
I mean, it's just-- you're
dealing with an inherently
unstable situation.
And as long as you
can enjoy that,
history becomes immensely
satisfying, I think,
to non-specialists.
But you've got to be careful,
because it's certainly not
the way history is done today.
So I often think, when
you go into a bookstore,
and you look at the
new books that are out,
you're going to see
a bunch of books
about historical figures, and
history, and everything else,
from authors.
Not historians, just authors,
because they're great
storytellers.
And they know how to tell
that story in a way that
relates to a non-specialist.
And I think the specialists
must hate that sometimes,
because they generalize,
and they do all the things.
But if you're creating the
next generation history fans--
and let's be honest, if
you're a history professor
and you want to teach people
who are interested in history,
somebody has got
to appetize them,
for lack of a better word.
Right?
Somebody's got to create
the next generation
of history professors.
Victor Davis Hanson, the
historian, he's a classicist.
And he wrote about how the
classicists are destroying
the next generation of people
who want to learn classics,
by making it so
devoid of that things
that an average person
would care about.
So I think, and I would hope,
that we're appetizing people,
for lack of a better word.
And people tell me that they've
become history majors because
of this stuff.
That's wonderful.
And then they can
write me later and say,
I used to love your show, till
I found out all the things wrong
about it.
And now that I'm a historian
I can explain those to you.
But, yeah, from a standpoint
of what we're doing,
I mean, I think it's a little
bit like the way an author
writes a book about
a historical subject,
and knows how to bring out the
things that appeal to someone
who's making a TV, or a movie.
It's a different thing, I think.
I think history's
become a science.
And I think by
becoming a science,
you lose some of the
elements that impact people
on a human level.
Does that make sense?
SPEAKER: Makes sense.
DAN CARLIN: Not intentionally,
just because somethings
are very hard to quantify.
SPEAKER: And coming back to
that human level, we've also
transitioned to an age
where some of the things
you wish you had--
on your episodes
where you say, I
wish I had known what this
person was thinking, writing,
feeling.
Some of that, we have now.
We have people being
able to directly record
their feelings--
record what happened
in digital media.
How do you think that
changes how we're then
going to look back at history,
at these time periods,
with this wealth of
additional direct information?
DAN CARLIN: Well, I've started
to adopt a term for what I do,
that other people use.
I don't like it.
But when I deal with people
who are talking about TV shows,
they all talk
about storytellers.
And there's this real
dearth, apparently,
of professional storytellers.
Which is why you have
these movies coming out
that are 1970s cartoons turned
into a feature length film,
and part four.
It's just a dearth of
storytellers, they tell me.
So I was breaking down what a
storyteller means, if you just
use the words story and telling.
And you think about
the modern world,
and how it opens up the
possibilities for anybody who
has--
we'll just play with
the idea of a gene,
but you know what I mean.
A storyteller gene.
Some of you out there
are great storytellers,
and it's almost
an innate quality.
Doesn't mean you can't improve
it, but it's an innate quality.
I had a grandfather who
was a great storyteller.
This opens up the
door-- the new media,
and everything in it--
with no gatekeepers.
We've gone away
from the whole idea
that someone can prevent you
from telling your stories.
Or that you somehow
have to please them
before they let you see if an
audience likes what you do.
So for storytellers,
this is a golden age.
Because you're going to have
more storytellers working
and telling stories
than you've ever
had in the history of the world.
And I always quote this
quote that may or may not
have been a Napoleon quote.
Some people say it's
a Joseph Stalin quote.
But it's that quantity
has a quality all its own.
And I used to go around selling
the idea of amateur content
in the 1990s.
And I would go to these
executives, and they would say,
nobody's going to like this.
It's going to be juvenile.
And if they were
any good, they'd
be they'd be making money
for what they're doing.
And I tried to
explain that, listen,
you're going to
have so much stuff,
that if even 0.05%
of it's good, there's
going to be a ton of
good things made out
by 15-year-old kids
in their basement.
So from a storytelling
standpoint,
the amount of people
doing this has exploded.
Which means even if
a lot of it is crap,
for lack of a better
word, a lot of it's not.
And that you have
a lot of people
that are working now, and
telling stories in a business
where there aren't that
many jobs for that.
So we've improved
the number of people
who have access to telling their
stories who are good at it.
The other side are the
stories, themselves.
There are a lot of people
who aren't good storytellers
at all, but have lived through
things-- or have relatives,
or friends, or people they know
who have lived through amazing
things--
who would love to document that.
Your grandfather fought in
the Second World War, lived
through some amazing things.
No one's going to know that,
right, after they're gone,
and after you're gone.
But that doesn't have
to be the case anymore.
You can record a
terrible podcast
with awful audio and
horrific storytelling skills,
but get that information
down in a way
that future historians
will see as nuggets of gold
that they can mine later.
Because if you imagine
how, 200 years from now,
they're going to look
back on this era,
and think about what
the historians are
going to have to work with,
compared to what we have now.
If you had TV shows that you
could view now from 1750,
how would that change
your view of people
200 and some years ago?
So I mean, I think from a
storytelling standpoint,
on the story side,
we're going to have
stories for historians that
dwarf any material they've ever
had available.
And we're going to
have storytellers
who would have died on
the vine somewhere telling
their friends in a bar
great stories, who are going
to be able to tell those
stories to thousands, tens
of thousands,
hundreds of thousands,
or millions of people.
And not just now,
but I always try
to say if we do a show
today, how many people
are going to have heard that
show 100 years from now?
So I mean, there's a
long game going on here
that old media
doesn't deal with.
Old media does, what's
the next ratings period,
is this show going to
be around in a year?
When you put your grandfather's
World War II experiences
in an audio form,
set in digital stone,
for lack of a better
word, you die, he dies.
200 years from now, some
historian finds that,
and your grandfather's
story becomes
part of a larger mosaic
of experiences that gets
added somewhere else.
In other words, people are
creating history every day now.
SPEAKER: Right
DAN CARLIN: In a
way that would have
been lost, even 15 years ago.
SPEAKER: And that
storytelling, I
think, you focus a lot on
your Martian perspective.
Have you been there?
DAN CARLIN: Yeah,
that's a nice way
of saying I have a really
weird way of seeing things.
SPEAKER: How do you ensure
that you retain that Martian
perspective in media that's
increasingly polarized
or homogeneous?
DAN CARLIN: Well,
I mean, I'm having
this problem with the political
show that we do, right now.
The show that we started doing
first was "Common Sense,"
and that was a show that
grew right out of the radio
shows I used to do.
And for lack of a better word,
politically I'm a reformer.
I think we have some systemic
problems that require
us working together to fix.
Now anything that requires
Americans working together
is a long shot, right
from the get go.
But I talked about
this for years.
And then what was
really weird to me
was that what was a long
shot when I started doing it
in the early 1990s,
all of a sudden--
because I think the trends
became more obvious to people--
started looking like it
wasn't such a long shot.
And maybe history
was turning my way.
And a couple of years ago I
thought, this is crazy, right?
I mean, we started this
show when nobody cared.
But the trends have
luckily fallen into place,
to where what I'm
talking about is actually
more relevant to people than
it was when I was in radio.
And then, of course,
strange things
began to happen in
our political system.
And I sat down, not that
long ago, and I said,
I feel like my political
viewpoints have been blown out
of the water by events.
And that somehow what I was
talking about went from, hey,
you could actually see
it potentially falling
into place, to
forget about that.
We are now so far
away from that,
that what I'm talking
about politically maybe
isn't relevant anymore.
And so I haven't done a
"Common Sense" show in a while,
because it's an
inspiration-based program.
And I feel, to be honest, as
lost as a lot of the country
does.
I don't feel like I
have anything to share.
I feel like I'm an observer,
like everyone else.
So you kind of have
to feel like you
know what you're
talking about, to talk
about these kinds of things.
And all of a sudden I felt
like as much of a novice
as everyone else.
I mean, I feel like we're
in an uncharted situation.
That I have no more
ability to understand where
we're going than anyone else.
And so I haven't felt
comfortable doing it.
And so, from a
politics standpoint,
I don't know what to
do about that show.
In terms of Martian perspective
for the history standpoint,
I mean, I feel like
that's who I am.
I'm not sure I could
be anything but that.
And just so you guys
know, I picked Martian
because there are
no overtones to it.
I mean, I tried to think, how
do you explain an outsider's
perspective without having some
baggage attached to any term
you can think of?
And I thought, well, what's the
baggage attached to Martian?
So it was a good way to say, I'm
different, but not in any way
you can easily classify.
SPEAKER: Makes sense.
Makes sense.
And how has that perspective
evolved from the radio days?
I think a lot of people
here are obviously--
they've been sampling
from a variety of media.
Radio is still a
part of our lives.
How do you feel working in
radio versus podcasts gives you
a different perspective?
DAN CARLIN: Radio
was awful for me,
so the perspective is very
different right off the bat.
Listen, we all understand,
we've all heard radio.
It's a very specific kind
of medium that's developed,
over 50 or 60 years,
a certain way.
If you go back and you
listen to old radio shows,
obviously there's a
lot more creativity.
There was a lot more theater
of the mind, as they called it.
The ability to have you sit by
a box with a voice coming out,
and you, in your head,
determine everything.
I was trying to explain
to my kids, the difference
between reading a book
or going and seeing
the movie about the book.
And the difference is, is
when you read the book,
you're all reading
the same words,
but you're conjuring up
different images in your head.
What does the main
character look like to you?
Right?
If I show you the
main character,
you don't have to think
about that anymore.
In radio, when you look at
the way stories were told--
and it was storytelling
a lot of the time.
I mean, radio obviously
had news, sports,
all the things it has now.
But it also had dramas, and
all these kinds of things
that the radio format really
doesn't allow for now.
And I remember an older
person who grew up on radio
said that it's like a muscle.
And if you don't use it, you
lose some of that ability.
So if I played an old radio
show for my 12-year-old,
she's going to be
bored to tears.
She's not going to get it.
It's not going to
mean anything to her.
And so by the time
I'm in radio, we
want to play with some
of the creative tools
that audio allows
you to have, but it's
such a restrictive venue.
It was then, and is more now.
Right?
You have a top of
the hour news break.
You have a break 10
minutes after the hour.
I mean, there's all
these things that
constrain what you
can do, and then
add to that the
fact that you have
to assume that your audience is
turning over every 15 minutes,
in large number.
Right?
You're getting into the car.
You're getting out of the car.
So what does that
mean I have to do?
I have to restate the same
things over and over again.
I mean, my moment in radio,
where I knew I was doomed,
happened when I had yet another
fight with a consultant who
told me that everyone
in the audience
has to know where I stand
on every political issue
within five minutes of
turning on the program.
Now, first of all,
nobody's saying,
OK, here are my views on
all the subjects of the day.
In other words,
what they meant is,
you have to be so
obviously identifiable,
that when they
hear you, they can
tell what your views
on abortion are,
because of what your views
on this other thing are.
And I said to him, that's
a cartoon character.
I said, that's not
a real human being.
He goes, we're not
in the business
of marketing real human beings.
In other words,
they were looking
for a cartoon character.
Now I didn't get
fired, so I must
have been at least passably OK.
But I never went the
cartoon character route.
And so when the chance to do
media on my terms showed up,
and you said, OK, this is
your creative white space,
and it's a giant space
that's all white.
There's no top of
the hour news breaks.
There's no resetting what you're
talking about, or who you are.
From a creative
standpoint, I lost my mind.
I would do 20 different
podcasts, if I could,
because I have ideas
for all these things.
Because it's just
such an amazing--
we do six hour shows sometimes.
Who does six hour shows?
Who lets you do six hour shows?
Right?
And so I'm intoxicated by
the creative white space.
And one of the
things about radio
was that that white
space was diminishing
the whole time I was in it.
By the time the 1996
Telecommunications Act
was passed, and we went
from having a radio station
owner that was in the building
with you, to an owner that's
on Wall Street selling stock
and owns 1,000 radio stations,
I mean, we went from
little white space to none.
SPEAKER: Right.
DAN CARLIN: And so, for me,
this opened up at just about
the same time, and it
was like an escape hatch.
It's perfect.
SPEAKER: Right.
DAN CARLIN: It's perfect.
SPEAKER: And how did
this change over the time
that you worked in the space?
In 2005 you started
your podcast.
2015, that's 10 years
later, "Serial" comes out.
"Serial" hits mainstream media.
You guys both win the best
podcast, in slightly different
categories, 2014, 2015.
Bringing a whole new
set of listeners,
and changing what it
means to be a podcast.
How did that affect your
show, and how did it change
how you approach the problem?
DAN CARLIN: It was the
continuation of a trend that
was already going on.
So when I got into
podcasting in 2005--
we always say we started
podcasting the same month
that iTunes started
supporting podcasts.
And when we did, there were
no professional content on it.
One of the great things that was
done to nurture the podcasting
space was not dividing
professional and amateur
content, and separating us.
So you don't have a big
link, when you first
go on there, that says, do
you want professional stuff,
or amateur stuff.
So by allowing us to compete
with anyone in the same space,
it became more of a meritocracy.
Now it didn't mean
that ESPN didn't
have huge advantages over you.
But it meant you're still
competing in the same space.
Now I always said that once
the pros got into podcasting,
it was a good thing
for everybody.
Because we're all raised on-- at
least I was, in my generation--
raised on this idea that
media is a zero sum game.
And if you're watching one
TV network at 8 o'clock,
you're not watching the other
TV network at 8 o'clock.
So no one has any interest
in telling you about what's
on the other network.
Podcasting's not like that.
You can promote
somebody else's podcast,
it doesn't hurt
your podcast at all.
So when the big boys
started coming in--
and I don't remember
who was first.
I think some of the sports
networks were the first ones.
And all they were doing
was rebroadcasting
their other content
using podcast
as a distribution vehicle.
I said, this is great.
Because once you
download a podcast,
you're a podcast listener.
It's no longer foreign.
You know how to do it.
And the biggest impediment
we had, when we started is--
I would go to dinner parties.
You want imagine uncomfortable,
you sit at a dinner party,
and the first question
anybody asks is,
so what do you do for a living?
In 2006, this is a 45
minute conversation.
And at the end, the
guy still doesn't
know what I do for a living.
Now it's not.
Right?
And so I think what
helped us in that space
is all of the
professionals saying,
yeah, download the podcast.
And then once you do, you
go, what are the podcasts
are there out there?
I know how to do that.
I've got a pod catcher.
I've got all these things.
So I think the pros
coming into it ended up
increasing the size
of the people who
are potential listeners,
and then we could grab them.
So how the industry has changed
is that we went from something
that no one knew what it was,
to something that everybody
below a certain age does.
And the respectability's
gone up.
No one assumes you're some kid
in a basement-- although kids
in basements can
do wonderful work.
They think that this
could be anything.
And they're right.
I mean, when you talk about
the numbers of listeners,
it's insane, sometimes.
Some of these-- "Serial" has
an insane number of listeners.
SPEAKER: Yeah, right.
And here at Google we certainly
cherish and celebrate the kid
in the basement with anything.
So I think a lot of people
here, especially engineers,
would love to know a little bit
more about how do you build it.
How do you put
together that podcast,
from idea to episode coming up?
DAN CARLIN: It's changed.
Once upon a time I could
walk into the studio,
and I would sit down--
or stand up-- and I would
record the whole thing, boom.
If I made a mistake--
a fatal mistake--
35 minutes into it, we turned
it off and we started over.
So finally the engineer
said, why are you doing that?
Why don't you just use-- see,
the problem started, actually,
with no cough button.
So in radio, you
have a cough button,
or a clear your throat button.
So you push it, clear your
throat, you're off air.
So there wasn't
anything like that.
So you try to clear your
throat 35 minutes into it
and say, ah, had
to clear my throat.
We have to start over.
So the engineer said, what?
[LAUGHTER]
Why don't you just
clear your throat,
and tell me about it, and I
will get rid of that later.
Which started the process
of, OK, this show was great.
I wanted to do 50 minutes.
49 minutes were
great, the ending
sucked, let's start over.
And he's like, no, no, no,
we're not starting over.
We're going to just record the
one minute that you didn't do.
And so slowly but surely
it became more that way.
And I was scared.
Because as a radio guy, not
knowing where this podcast was
going, I'm thinking,
if this doesn't work,
I've got to go dive
back into radio.
And what if I lose my chops?
What if I can't--
now I need editing.
Right?
I can't go in there and speak
for 20 minutes off the cuff
anymore.
He said, do you really
care so much about--
so I mean it was a process of me
embracing this new opportunity
wholeheartedly in
a way that said,
what do we need to do
in this kind of venue
to do the best
show in this venue?
And forget the idea that
you have to worry about,
I've got to go back
to radio someday,
so I better do-- you know.
And once we did
that, there was not
only a liberation, but
unfortunately, maybe,
for the listeners, an extended--
I mean we'd get
longer and longer.
And these shows just got so--
I mean, like, when
I do six hour shows,
I don't want to do
a six hour show.
That's not a feature,
that's a bug.
[LAUGHTER]
But if I had to record
them all without stopping,
there would be no
six hour shows.
There might not be
40 minute shows.
So the way it's changed
is the embracing
of the techniques of how to
do this, which we're learning.
One of the things that I
talk to other big podcasters
about is, we kind of try
to share the information,
because there are no metrics.
Right?
So you go, what are
you guys seeing?
And how do you make money?
And how is this working for you?
And the funny thing
is, is that if you
looked at all the top podcasts
and say, how do you make money,
they actually have
different models.
Because it's really
tied to what you do,
and the kind of
production you have.
I mean, for example, I get out--
I'm ashamed to say--
about 2.5 shows a year at
this point-- history shows.
If I had to live
off advertising--
and I will do more
than one ad per show--
OK, well you can't do that.
But if you do three
shows a week--
like Joe Rogan
does-- and you could
do four or five ads
per show, that's
a viable monetary
solution for you.
So we actually all have
different kinds of approaches.
So we sell the
old history shows.
After a couple of years,
take them off the free feed,
and we sell them.
Well, most people have
different kinds of shows.
These are evergreen, right?
They're as good
when you get them
a year from now, as they
were when we released them.
If they sucked, they
suck just as bad.
But most people can't do that.
If you're talking politics,
like I do on the other show,
those shows are like a car,
and you drive them off the lot,
and they lose half
their value right away.
And so I guess what the long
answer to your question is,
we're learning.
And we've been learning.
And it's a unique medium, and
so there are unique things.
And there are no metrics, and
so we're all learning together.
I was just at the podcast
convention two weeks ago,
and it's really interesting
hearing the different lessons
that people learn, because
they're doing different things,
but stuff that might
apply to what you do too.
So you and I were talking
about the infancy.
You're all employees at Google,
and you're used to all this.
But if you think about the
fact that we are literally
at the very start of this--
it doesn't seem like it,
because I've been
doing it since 2005.
But what is this going
to look like in 50 years?
And what's the societal
impact going to be?
And you may just
think it's a podcast,
but if you're the
government of China,
and you're thinking
about your people
doing political podcasts,
that is a destabilizing force.
And so I think what we're
going to find out later--
and I think we're seeing it
even now in its infancy--
this is dangerous stuff.
Like every de-stabilising
technology is, right?
Letting people communicate to
broad masses of other people
is untested stuff,
and no dictatorship
in the history of the
world ever wanted that.
So I keep trying to tell
myself that as far as we think
we come in this, we're
at the very beginning
of the beginnings, still.
SPEAKER: Right.
And we talked earlier about
how some of this content
is so appealing, because
it feels like you're
filling a void, potentially,
in the education
that a lot of your
listeners have,
in terms of getting the
context of the history
that you describe.
How do you view your role in
the broader education story?
DAN CARLIN: Yeah, I'm
uncomfortable with that.
And I'm uncomfortable with it
because I was a history major,
as I said.
And one thing a history major
with a BA in history knows
is that you're not a historian.
Right?
And you really understand
that really well.
So I'm having dinner with
my mother-in-law one day.
And I always give
her credit for this,
because I'm doing the
political podcast at the time.
And I'm regaling her with one
of my wonderful dinnertime
stories, which are
bloody and horrible,
and they sound a lot
like the podcast.
And I think as a
way to dissuade me
from talking like that
at dinner, she said,
why don't you do a
podcast about this?
And I said, because
I'm not qualified.
I said, I'm not a historian.
I can't teach history.
She said, I didn't
realize you had
to have a PhD to tell stories.
This is the first time the
storytelling thing came up.
And I went, hmm.
I said, OK, that's
an interesting point.
And then I thought, well,
OK, how you tell the stories?
So if you go listen to the first
history podcast we ever did,
I think it's 15 minutes long.
It shows you what I was
thinking at the time.
We thought we would
do a show just talking
about all the weird
stuff in a story.
But we weren't going to
tell you about the story,
because we assumed you'd
show up as a history fan,
you'd know the story.
So if I'm talking about
Alexander the Great
and Hitler-- which I
was in the first show--
I assume you know that.
So we just talked
about the weird things.
Right?
So the feedback starts coming
in, and people are saying,
yeah, we like these twisty weird
"Twilight Zone" things you say,
but we don't know the story.
So you kind of go,
OK, well I guess
I've got to give
enough of the story
so that you could enjoy
the "Twilight Zone" things.
And slowly but surely
that leads to us
telling more of the story.
So we had to figure out
why on Earth you should
trust me telling you the story.
And so we had to invent things.
One of the things we invented--
because I think we're
the only one who
does it, because I can't
imagine anybody needs it--
we call them audio footnotes.
So if I was writing
a book, and I'm just
Joe Blow with a BA in history,
why should you trust me?
I'm going to say a
fact in the book,
and then I'm going to have a
little footnote at the bottom
that says, well, I got this
information from somebody
who you should trust, and you
can go look it up yourself.
And there was nothing comparable
to that in the audio space.
And so that's when we
started quoting people.
And once again, you've got to be
careful about doing that, too.
You don't want anybody's work
to be plagiarized, or anything,
but you want to
make sure though,
that when I say this
happened, that I give you
somebody who you can believe.
You know, so-and-so
said this happened,
and then you integrate
that into the story.
Now all of us understand that
every historian self-selects.
And so just because historian
A says this happened,
that doesn't mean historian
B agrees with them.
So then you get competing
audio footnotes.
So we developed this idea
of, OK, well this historian
says this, and
this one says that.
Well, this turned
out to be great.
We had no idea that
people didn't get--
because they're
not history majors.
They haven't spent a
lot of time on this.
They don't realize that there's
not one view of history.
So one guy wrote me,
and he had a great line.
He said I didn't realize there
was like an MSNBC Fox News
version of history,
and there always was.
[LAUGHTER]
And so this is something
that in history they
call historiography.
Right?
The practice of writing history.
The practice of
selecting sources.
Because there's always
a selection process.
Right?
And this is something historians
have been criticized forever.
So once we started highlighting
this element of history,
people were like, I had no idea.
But it became something that
was part of the audio footnotes.
And so learning how
to do this gig--
and I would suggest we're still
learning how to do this gig--
required us to invent ways to
get around our own limitations.
Limitation number one is I'm
a storyteller, I guessed,
and I know I'm not a historian.
So how do I assure you that
you're getting something
that you can trust?
I quote somebody who's valid,
and who you should trust.
And then I quote somebody
who disagrees with him, who's
also valid, you should trust.
So learning how to do this job.
SPEAKER: Makes sense.
So I have really
enjoyed getting a chance
to ask you some of the
pressing questions on my mind.
I'd like to open it
up to the audience.
DAN CARLIN: Yeah.
SPEAKER: If you'd like
to ask Dan a question,
please step up to the mic.
DAN CARLIN: Love to
hear from any of you.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And just line up behind the mic.
DAN CARLIN: Thank you
for coming, by the way.
SPEAKER: Perfect.
If we get started right there?
AUDIENCE: Hey, Dan, huge fan.
DAN CARLIN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a
serious question.
But just first, is Ben up
there with you right now?
DAN CARLIN: Did you
ever want to meet him?
He's been here the whole time.
AUDIENCE: Just checking.
Good.
So my question is
kind of about how
you pick what you talk about.
In July I was actually
sitting on Cemetery Ridge,
looking over Pickett's Charge--
DAN CARLIN: Wow.
AUDIENCE: --and thinking about
"Blueprint for Armageddon,"
because that was
a huge cannonade,
and it was a huge
artillery action.
Well, one, could you
please do the Civil War?
But two, how do you pick?
DAN CARLIN: Well, first of
all, isn't it interesting
that all of our shows
sound like they would make
great heavy metal band names?
SPEAKER: Yeah, right.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN CARLIN: You know, here's
the problem with that.
And like a guy wrote me
the other day, he said,
would you please talk
about 17th century India?
And it's such a compliment
to think that I could
speak about 17th century India.
Because what happens
is, is that we
have this period of time where
I can do research for program.
But it's not enough time
for me to educate myself
from scratch on anything.
So all the topics
we pick are things
that I have a good
foundation on, myself.
And it's funny.
I have two kids,
and one of them has
a brain that's a little like
mine, in terms of how it works.
And it's funny, because
she'll get into a subject
intensely, and stay into it
for several months, or a year,
and then move on
to something else.
But she will remember
every single thing
she learned about it then.
And that's how my mind works.
And so all these subjects
we talk about in the show
are things that I
was really into once,
and have a pretty
good foundation about.
And then what I have
to do after that
is begin to re-educate myself
on all the new stuff that's
been discovered or written
about since the last time
I paid close attention to it.
And so all these
subjects we talk about
are things that I've
already been interested in,
and I know something about.
The Civil War has never
been an interest of mine,
because I don't like civil wars.
And I don't like civil wars,
because when I was a military--
I still am a military
history nut--
I don't like armies that are
fighting each other that are
mirror images of each other.
This is the silliest
thing in the world to base
what you're interested on.
But I like the contrast of
Greeks against Persians.
I don't want to see
Greeks against Greeks.
So I'm not going to talk to you
about the Peloponnesian War,
because it bores me.
Right?
So that's my problem.
Civil wars are interesting
in a societal sense.
But from a military
sense, I don't
want to watch two
armies that are mirror
images of each other go at it.
So people keep thinking, when
are you going to the Civil War?
I might do reconstruction
afterwards.
I might do the period
leading up to it.
But I find both of those
more interesting than the war
itself.
I know that heresy, but--
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you could speak more
about the structure you've
developed for the stories.
And maybe how you take content
and put it into buckets
to create something that's
compelling and hooks listeners.
DAN CARLIN: That's a
really good question.
And I don't know--
I wish I could claim more
of a conscious desire.
I mean, sometimes I'll
sit down and I'll say,
could we tell this
story backwards?
I mean, there's
fun ways that you
sit down right at
the outset, and you
look at what you want
to say, and you say,
OK, there are multiple
ways to tell every story.
The most obvious way
is the linear way.
The problem is that
that's a very boring way
to tell a story.
But if the story is
very complicated--
like we mentioned
the First World War--
that's a really hard
story to follow.
So you end up sometimes having
to choose the linear option,
because it's easier
to make sense of.
But we often do sit
down-- and the one thing
I don't ever want to do is
have a template for this.
So sometimes we'll
deliberately do something
as a way to screw up any idea in
your mind that we have a plan.
Right?
We're going to make sure that
the last show was like this,
so this other one's
going to be like that.
So that you get this idea that
you don't know what's coming,
and you don't know how
we're going to do it.
And it keeps us
from getting bored,
and keeps it from
turning into a formula.
So the first thing we do is we
look at what we've done lately
and say, OK, can we do this
new one differently than that?
And that's truthfully the
part that's most satisfying,
because that's the
creative process.
And that's when you sit down--
and these are really hard
to do, needless to say.
I mean, six hour audio
is really hard to do.
But afterwards the
feeling of satisfaction,
if people like it, there's not
much that compares to that.
And I tell my wife all the time,
because I'm such a wreck when
these things are done.
I mean, the studio looks
like college finals week.
There's pizza boxes.
There's caffeine everywhere.
And you're so burnt
out that there's
a week of recovering afterwards.
And she said to me once, she
said, do you really like this?
And I said, I really like it.
And I said I really
like the idea
that I can look back on this
and say I used every brain cell.
Right?
It killed me, but that's
how you know you really--
whatever potential is
there-- and potential's
a weird haunting
thing, isn't it?
Because you could become
the president and not
live up to your potential.
But I like the idea that
I'm kicking my rear end
and using everything I have.
And then when people like it,
on top of that, well, I mean,
listen, we should all be--
I mean, that's a real gift.
I mean, it's really lucky.
And when I think of how upset
I was in radio for so long,
to be doing this and have
people reacting so well,
I hope everybody gets to feel
this, because it's a great--
and that's the creative thing.
I mean, to be able
to do creative work,
and have people like it, and
make a living doing it, I mean,
who wouldn't give your
right arm for that?
So I hope that
answers the question.
That doesn't really
help you understand
the creative process.
But there's no scripts.
Because it would sound
scripted, wouldn't it?
I think that's probably how
you get a six hour show, too--
no scripts, it's just
a lot of rambling on.
But I simply write down the
things that I'm interested in.
And I will say that I
thought about the difference
between history and
storytelling in this sense,
that it's a different criteria.
So if you're a
historian writing, say,
the history of Julius Caesar,
you're going to do a triage,
and you're going to say, OK,
what has to be in this story,
versus what doesn't.
Some of the things that aren't
going to make your triage
list as a historian are going to
make my list as a storyteller.
So for example, I
read something once
that said Caesar, in his home,
grew up with an ancestor wall.
And I think you might have
seen this in "Game of Thrones,"
or something, because my friend
Dan Weiss ripped that off.
But it's a wall of--
I think it was wax
faces of his ancestors--
with bios underneath him.
So when you grow up as
a kid, you look at this,
and you see what
your family's done.
And it's supposed to prompt
you to want to emulate that.
Now, if you're writing a history
book about Julius Caesar,
and you've got 400
pages, and no more,
you might leave that out,
because it's not really
important to the history.
But in the story,
it's fantastic,
and that makes it in the story.
So as a storyteller
you're self-selecting
different things.
I want to blow your mind
from a historical standpoint.
If I'm writing to an
academic audience,
different things make
it into the story.
Drier things, maybe,
less interesting things.
But so when we're coming
up with how we do this,
I read all these books, I write
down all the weird things--
including all the
important things-- and then
you try to figure
out what makes it in.
And because there's no
scripts, sometimes things
I really want in the
story don't make it in.
And sometimes things
that I thought,
maybe I'll steer clear of this,
somehow make it into the audio
when I'm on autopilot.
And so there is an
improvisational jazz format
to this, where there's
certain points I need to hit,
but within those
points I can freeform.
And that's kind of the
design, if that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAN CARLIN: Sure.
SPEAKER: I think we can just
try to squeeze in a couple more,
real quick.
AUDIENCE: So one of
my favorite episodes
was the talk you
had with Sam Harris.
DAN CARLIN: That's
interesting, OK.
AUDIENCE: And I
was wondering if--
two things.
Are there any future plans
to kind of continue that?
And is there anyone
that you would
like to kind of collaborate
with on a future episode?
DAN CARLIN: I forgot how the
Sam Harris thing came about.
But Sam's got a podcast,
and I have a podcast.
And we did something Sam
called a cross-cast, where
we basically did the same
show for our audiences
at the same time.
There's someone who works
with Sam that got a hold of me
recently, and wanted to
do something on video.
I guess this, to me, boils
down to the same thing
the political show boils down
to, a little bit, in the sense
that I don't know
how comfortable I
am in political
discussions anymore,
because I feel like we're
a little off the map,
if you will.
And the normal
parameters with which
I'm accustomed to discussing
things aren't normal anymore.
And I have to be honest.
You think, OK, I've been
following this political system
for years.
I was basically a PoliSci minor.
You think you know what
you're talking about.
But if you'd asked me five
years ago about the idea,
for lack of a better
word, of racism coming
to the fore the
way it has, I would
have told you you were crazy.
I mean, I thought
this was dying out.
I mean, I really thought that--
I grew up watching
"All in the Family,"
and you had this
Archie Bunker character
that was supposed to
be a middle aged man
who had all of these views
from another time period,
running into the
new way of looking
at things, which is much more
the way we look at things now.
And the implication was that
you can't change these people,
but eventually
they will die out.
I could not have
been more wrong.
So why would you listen to me?
Why would I talk about this,
when I didn't see that coming?
And so to discuss
something with Sam Harris--
listen, he's a fabulously
intelligent guy,
and I enjoyed our conversations.
You know, if you heard it, I
think Sam was pretty serious.
But I was laughing.
I was having a good time.
But I'm not sure
laughing and having
a good time about the
political situation right
now is the proper approach.
And I don't know what
the proper approach is.
So in answer to your
question, I think
until I figure that out, I'm
not sure how much of that
I want to do.
Does that make sense?
I really feel like an
observer at this point,
when it comes to that,
rather than somebody
that can explain what it means.
Because I didn't see it coming.
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAN CARLIN: Do you
really want me explaining
something I'm not sure about?
That might be a
better way to put it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I actually came
up here to ask about
how you draw the line
between what historians do,
and what historical
storytellers do.
But I think you already answered
that in a previous question.
So as long as I'm
here, I'm going
to go to a backup question.
DAN CARLIN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned being excited
about the possibility
of essentially producing
a much larger volume of source
material for future historians.
That anyone can get
their story down.
There is no end to how
much of it we'll produce.
But you've also mentioned
that historians see history
differently, partly because
of their perspectives,
but also partly because
they've absorbed
different sets of source
material to different degrees.
Right?
So putting those
two things together,
do you think the practice
of history, as it's
done today can, survive
the explosion in the amount
of source material?
Is there going to be any one
that can absorb all of that
and synthesize it?
DAN CARLIN: It's
an old joke, but it
concerns with the
difference between
modern and ancient history.
And someone once said--
it may have been
one of my teachers--
had said something
about that if you're
a historian of
the ancient world,
your job is to find
needles in haystacks,
but there's almost no haystacks.
Whereas your job as
a modern historian
is, there are
haystacks everywhere,
which haystack do you pick?
I ran into the same
problem in news.
Because I was in LA, and
when you open up the news
file in Los Angeles on what to
cover that day, it's that big.
And your job is to go,
no, no, no, no, no,
and what makes the final cut.
So then I get a job
in Western Oregon.
And I show up, and I look at
the file the next, morning
and there's one
piece of paper in it.
And the entire job is different.
Your job is to go find
news stories, as opposed
to weeding down.
So the historian's job
is the same problem.
Where if you talk about a
historian 100 years from now,
think of all the
podcasts that they're
going to have to weed through.
The blog posts, and-- so it's
not a needle in a haystack job
anymore.
It's oh my god, a field
full of haystacks, which one
do you think the needle's in?
And the process of selection
as a historian is often--
not to speak for them--
but is often concerned with
what they're talking about.
So let's say you're doing the
history of the New York Yankees
baseball team.
OK, there's a
self-selection right there,
that helps you
winnow things down.
Right?
So you found three haystacks,
and those are your haystacks.
And you start working
within that realm.
The problem is, is if
somebody's writing a history
book on baseball, OK, there's
going to be crossover.
But there also might
be disagreement.
The guy writing specifically
about the New York Yankees
may come up with ideas,
concepts, views, or conclusions
that are different
from a guy looking
at it on a more macro level,
with baseball history,
in general.
In my mind-- and I think this
is how historians would do it.
I'm not going to speak for them.
But, I mean, I think the collage
of all the different historians
together-- this
mosaic, that if you
add them all together--
helps give you
a more 360 view of things.
So that in the same
way today, I think
if you're an intelligent
well-rounded person
you're reading
multiple news sources.
Hopefully from multiple angles,
and if you're really good,
from multiple countries.
Take that, and do the
same thing with history.
Where you're saying, OK,
here's a Roman view of somebody
who liked Julius Caesar
versus, Suetonius,
who's a gossip
columnist who writes
all the bad stuff about him.
And you throw all
this stuff together,
and you realize, OK, a
lot of this may be false.
But when I look at the
mosaic and stand back
from it, what does it convey?
And so I think that's
a good way to describe,
like when we do the
audio footnotes,
but we'll give
you two historians
who disagree about something.
And the tendency is to go,
well what did I just learn?
Right?
One said it was black.
The other said it was white.
Did I really learn anything?
But being able to understand
that two intelligent people
who've looked at
the source material
came to different
conclusions is, in of itself,
a useful piece of
information for you today.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
DAN CARLIN: I mean, if 500 years
from now, the historians have
to try to figure out
21st century US politics,
and all they have to go on is an
MSNBC feed and a Fox News feed,
you're going to have to blend
those somehow, and come up
with a mosaic.
And the funny part about
it is, 500 years from now,
you can still have as
divided a viewpoint over what
that history is, as you do now.
Right?
The ones who say, well
that MSNBC version
is much more close to the truth.
And I think maybe
that's the part
that people listening to the
podcast found most interesting,
was that there isn't just--
I mean, that history's
not like math.
Right?
Two plus two equals four.
The Roman Empire did this.
And it isn't like that, because
it's composed of human beings,
and we're variable.
Right?
And open to interpretation.
Hard to quantify.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
All right, thank you so much.
Thanks for all the questions.
Thank you for your
detailed answers.
DAN CARLIN: That's it?
SPEAKER: So I just want
to remind everybody
"Hardcore History" is available
on your favorite podcast
platform, including
Google Play Music.
We'd like to--
DAN CARLIN: [LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: --thank Dan again
for your time, and all
your considerations.
DAN CARLIN: Thank
you for coming.
Thank you, everybody,
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]